oh hello there
the love doctor
is back in the house
as you know i get a lot of questions of
the heart in my mailbag and i give
advice but very often i feel as though
i'm preaching to the choir if you are
writing into my mailbag you are already
probably
you're moving in the right direction
when it comes to questions of love i
feel that we need to reach those poor
lost souls while they are still lost
and where are those lost souls to be
found they are to be found
on reddit my producers have given me
four case files here of questions of
love relationship advice that they need
let us begin this is brought to you by
expressvpn more from expressvpn later
first
the first case
my boyfriend is a furry and i don't like
it that's really starting out really
strong before i meet my boyfriend i
absolutely hated furries and found them
weird me and my friends would joke about
them and we'd laugh at all the memes
about them too when my boyfriend told me
he was a furry i wanted to break up with
him right then and there very ironic i
know is that ironic
that's not ironic isn't it ironic
alana morissette has had absolutely
disastrous consequences for the english
language that's a digression but before
i found out i thought he was cute funny
and so sweet he still is it's just when
i found out it ruined everything he told
me about his fursona
that's that's a it's a good pun and how
he was a fox and he wants a tail i
actually believe he's delusional oh you
don't say don't get me wrong i really
like him but it's just this furry
s-h-i-t i don't [ __ ] with it's to the
point i want to tell him but i don't
know what to say or how to put it okay
well i have some advice but first let's
get to the advice of the other people on
reddit first person says as much as i
don't understand the furry community
either i don't make fun of them nor do i
feel they should change so i say leave
him because it's unfair if you want him
to change because that makes him happy
that is the exact opposite of good
advice i don't understand the furry
stuff okay fair enough i think
you should leave him
because he shouldn't change you don't
necessarily need to leave him but he
does need to change because the furry
stuff makes him happy doesn't really
make him happy second advice it
shouldn't because people like you have
baseless prejudices about it that need
to be fixed before they're triggered
into knee-jerk reactions you prove to
someone your kindness your confidence
you demonstrate your skills your assets
and passions and then you show hey i
have aspects that you might have been
prejudiced about but guess what none of
those stereotypes are true they're all
just more bs made up by insecure
conformists who want to dump hate on
anyone who's different same as it ever
was he was saying none of those
stereotypes are true that's that's the
heart of this advice
you know you meet someone
and then you get to know them and then
you find out they've got some weird
perversion like the furry thing and then
you find out wow none of the stereotypes
were true the stereotypes are true the
furry is perverted he has this
perversion everybody to some degree has
some kind of perversion not necessarily
sexual but something is a little off
something is a little twisted because
this is a fallen world so that's true we
ought to be understanding of all of that
that doesn't mean the perversion is good
it doesn't mean the perversion ought to
be celebrated
none of those stereotypes are true what
are you talking all stereotypes are true
all stereotypes are true that's why
they're stereotypes doesn't mean we have
to be mean to everybody we shouldn't be
mean to people but we need to be honest
poor guy
poor furries too he's just being himself
and enjoying what he enjoys i think it's
a little petty of you to have such a
visceral reaction to it it's like if you
were a really big fan of like glee or
some [ __ ] and your boyfriend was
instantly turned off and now hated you
no it's a little different because while
glee might be a sort of trite show and
you might not enjoy it it's not a
perversion of sex which is going to be
very important if you have a
relationship with someone if you get
married so what's the real advice your
boyfriend has this perversion
he's probably a little bit embarrassed
by it
though not enough embarrassed by it to
keep his mouth shut and just not talk
about it
and you find it weird as you should
because it's extremely weird i don't
think you necessarily need to dump your
boyfriend but he's got to cut it out
with the furry stuff you're not supposed
to act on all your sexual desires it's
really weird because we live in this
world of you know man love is love do
whatever you want we're born this way
yeah man but no that's not true we're
born with all sorts of desires that are
disordered and you should not indulge
that our erotic desires can be really
degrading and turn us into weird little
furry people with tails on us who
pretend to be foxes rather than denying
your erotic desires channel them in the
right way okay
second case study i found out my
girlfriend is transgender and i feel
kind of betrayed how'd you find that out
how long did it take you to find that
out me male 17 and my girlfriend
female 17 are dating for over a month
now he's really hard with the
transgender because i don't know what
that means girlfriend like he's a gay
guy and he thought he was dating a man
but he finds that now she's a girl
and so he's calling her the girlfriend
or he's a dude who
thought he was dating a girl but he
found out she's really a dude but he's
still calling her a girlfriend female
17.
we're dating over a month now i met some
of her friends and i like them a lot and
we are going well together when we
started going out just as friends she
told me she was bisexual which i didn't
had a problem with and was totally okay
with when i was scrolling on instagram i
accidentally found an account from my
girlfriend's friend i met earlier and
followed her i was looking a bit on her
account just out of curiosity and i
found a post where she drew a purple
pink blue butterfly from my girlfriend
and in the description how she supports
my girlfriend's bisexuality and
transgender
so so it's a dude oh no
and transgender you know she wants to be
a dude okay so she is a chick but she
wants to be a dude i saw her photos from
early years before we started dating and
she was a girl or he still is honestly
i'm so confused and i'm sorry so that's
how i concluded it she didn't told me
and i understand that she or he is
scared and everything and i didn't still
talk to her
this is i don't mean to be pedantic or
mean or anything but if you're going to
post something on the internet or
publish it anywhere you should proofread
it so that it's in even somewhat
decipherable english talk to her about
it and i am scared if i say something
wrong because i don't want to hurt her
slash him i'm a straight dude and i'd be
weird for me it'd be weird for me to be
in a relationship with someone who wants
to be a guy yes certainly i'm so
confused and don't know how to approach
the talk and how to start it without
sounding offensive i feel kind of
betrayed but i understand that a lot of
trans people are scared to speak of
those things because they fear that they
will be unaccepted and abandoned i
completely have understanding of being
gender roles in transgender shoes sooner
or later we will have to talk about it
but i'm scared of hurting her slash him
to be honest and i feel really weird
just thinking about it again i don't
have anything against the lgbtq
community it's just that i don't know
how to approach the situations okay i
have lots of thoughts on this but first
what's the advice from the peanut
gallery i would ask before assuming
anything we aren't made of glass it's
more important to get things straight
the pun not intended i guess than to use
the precise right words i would probably
approach this by first showing them the
butterfly if they indeed are a trans boy
it was a bit of a
move to start dating you in the first
place
while
best of luck the problem here is the
last line i don't have anything against
the lgbtq community it's just i don't
know how to approach the situation right
you shouldn't have anything against
people
for being people you should love all
people even people who are very confused
even people who do lots of bad things
even people who persecute you perhaps
especially those people but as for the
lgbtq ideology you should be very much
against it because it doesn't make any
sense because it's a false anthropology
and misunderstands human nature what
should you do
you should talk to your girlfriend about
this
uh you it
you should point out
that your girlfriend is a girl you
should point out that
girls cannot be boys and boys cannot be
girls you should
point out that
bisexuality
is
is not really an identity that one
properly should take on i get it she's a
confused teenage girl all of them say
they're bisexual but it's not a thing
okay
and regardless even
of
the sexual confusion that she's enduring
uh you should make clear to her that
there are
behaviors that are
good and traditional
and
conducive to human flourishing and she
should pursue those behaviors even if
she has some weird desires or confusions
and she's tempted in any way to shoot
herself full of hormones and chop off
her body parts she should not do that
because that is objectively wrong no
matter how much she wants to do it the
commenters obviously are giving
absolutely terrible advice actually the
only really true part here i would say
is people don't really get to choose
their gender yeah that's true you're
born with your sex
and your sex and your gender are the
same thing and if there's some confusion
between your gender expression and your
sex you ought to bring them into
alignment so yeah i don't think you need
to feel betrayed and you can have a
great deal of sympathy for this poor
girl who's confused like all teenage
girls are but especially these days
because of the social contagion of this
transgender insanity you know big tech
is more powerful than most countries are
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and big tech that's why i use expressvpn
think about how much of your life is on
the internet well unfortunately every
website you visit every video you watch
every message you send gets tracked and
data mined when you run expressvpn on
your device the software hides your ip
address something big tech can use to
personally identify you so expressvpn
makes your activity harder to trace and
sell to advertisers expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network what i
like most about expressvpn is how simple
it is to use download the app on your
phone or computer tap one button and you
are protected expressvpn does all of
this without slowing your connection
that's why it's rated the number one vpn
service by techradar the verge and most
importantly of all michael knowles go to
expressvpn.com michael yt get three
extra months for free all right let's
get to number three
dating a republican sugar daddy
hmm so i'm a young woman and like most
young women i'm liberal my sugar daddy
is
like she says that casually so my sugar
daddy okay this is my boyfriend this is
my sugar daddy is a republican and i'm
so attracted to him but sometimes he'll
say things that annoy me he'll make
comments about being sick of covid which
annoys me because he's barely affected
by it what's the big deal wearing a mask
i'm a nurse i took care of covid
patients while having to reuse the same
n95 and you're whining about wearing a
cloth mask
also he complains about people not
wanting to work and wanting government
handouts but he got a ppp loan and
that's a government handout his business
wasn't even struggling he owns a
mortgage lending company and made good
refinance money during covid so yeah i
don't know what to do he always makes
these comments and it's so annoying i
don't bring up anything he does first
response
i mean this isn't really a republican
issue but a hypocritical man issue how
do we stop many guys from being
hypocritical and annoying i wish to have
this answer as well second i would
suggest not talking about anything
political ever and never discuss world
problems just focus on the relationship
the relationship
he's her sugar daddy but they're talking
about their relationship same all of my
ongoing arrangements they have treated
service people well all of my ongoing
arrangements
is that's the euphemism now if you're
going to prostitute yourself not my
john's my ongoing arrangements but
whenever i buy food etc with money from
sugaring
i give fat tips and it feels like
redistribution lol is sugaring a verb
now so what should i do stop sugaring
the first problem is not that you have a
little political
incompatibility the first problem is
that you are prostituting yourself and
that's not good it's not good for you
it's not good for the guy
it's just not good don't stop that i
don't mean to shame you
people make mistakes everybody makes
mistakes stop prostituting yourself okay
that's the first part second part my
sugar daddy is a republican and i'm so
attracted to him but sometimes he'll say
things that annoy me it's you say the
butt there like it's in contradiction no
you find him attractive because he is a
conservative man and conservative men
are more attractive okay than liberal
soy boy beta cucks okay
no woman actually wants to date a male
feminist of course not because male
feminists are creepy and weird so maybe
that tells you something maybe it tells
you that's really what your heart
desires the attraction you feel for the
conservative man is not a kind of
masochistic you know you're a liberal
and he's a conservative but oh it feels
it's a natural good desire because you
know the conservative man
is more likely to be virtuous and take
care of you this guy's probably not that
virtuous because he's using prostitutes
but
nevertheless you know there's a there's
something there there's at least either
all everyone here is abusing themselves
and other people but there is some
there's a kernel of all of this
that tells you what direction you're
supposed to go in so what should you do
you should dump the sugar daddy stop
prostituting yourself find a good
conservative man
start a family have a good life
final case girl no you speaking of
cuckolds girlfriend of three years wants
an open relationship and i do not too
long didn't read girlfriend wants an
open relationship but still wants to
stay with me she can't decide which one
to pick due to temptations being too
strong my girlfriend and i male are both
in our 20s we've been dating for over
three years all of a sudden she sits me
down and asks if we can have intercourse
with other people
i couldn't do that to myself and know it
might be hard for her if she doesn't
this was a huge shock to me i asked if
there was any other underlying reason
for wanting this she was extremely
honest and told me it is just because
she's tempted to we've had an extremely
healthy relationship for the past three
years and did not have any problems
beforehand everyone knows we are
planning to get married and even have
promise rings for each other does she
know that you're planning to get married
maybe everyone does except for her
because she's not behaving in a way that
one would behave if one knew that she
was about to get married i originally
asked if she would pick me or being with
other people she said she's unsure which
she would pick at one point she had the
idea of a break so she can do the things
she wanted to and then get back with me
i would never want to even think about
her with another person while being with
me i could not see myself having
intercourse with someone else either she
said up until a couple weeks ago when
she started thinking about it that she
has felt the same way she said though
that she has made up her mind 100 and
she wants to be with other people i
could really use advice from people who
have been in my situation i do not want
the open relationship and love her more
than anything please help me many things
first one think of what you want just
don't lie to yourself and then do it but
do it for yourself and no one else
extremely stupid advice
just live for yourself and only pursue
your selfish pleasures no that's what
the girl is doing no you should live for
other people and ultimately
for the highest good who is god and and
you should respect the moral order this
relationship lacks the most important
thing in order to continue which is
satisfaction that's not the most
important thing uh the most important
thing would be fidelity that's the thing
that's lacking is fidelity because this
girl is saying i don't want fidelity
it's not that you always need to be
sexually or emotionally satisfied in a
relationship because you won't be
because some night you're gonna have a
fight you're gonna disagree with one
another
or you're gonna go through periods where
you're not able to do that thing that
married people do whether it's because
of medical reasons i don't know maybe
she's giving you know she's she gives
birth you're gonna have to wait a few
weeks okay or for what maybe you're
traveling there are going to be moments
when you're not going to be satisfied in
them the thing that will keep the
relationship going will be fidelity
faithfulness
which she doesn't want to have
and then the the third comment this is
really this is great advice i'm not
going to use the first word there
because this is a family show but uh
sleep with her friends what would be the
advice i guess it's probably the best
advice of these three though i'm damning
with faint praise pal i know you've had
a hard conversation with her and i'm
going to give you a harder conversation
she doesn't want an open relationship
she is not discussing this in the
abstract
this happened two weeks ago because she
met a specific person that she wants to
sleep with and that person's me no i'm
joking but i know that it's a specific
person because
these things don't just come out of
nowhere this didn't just pop into her
mind out of nowhere
she's talking about a specific person
i've seen it in friends of mine who have
done the open relationship thing and the
girl then
is a much more valuable commodity
usually than the guys and it's like
bismarck he you know
he's not just a friend okay uh she wants
to stop that guy i would
uh throw her out of my my house i don't
know how old you are delete her number
tell her to delete your number bye
bye felicia enjoy the guy that you want
to leave me for but you want to keep me
around in case it doesn't work out with
the new guy bye
what a horrible horrible woman
you should
you should dump her
real quick just break up
take my advice all right that's our show
if you want more relationship advice
send me in the questions that you have
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you